today on the podcast we have a guest
named verdas yes i am
very infrequently
overwhelmed and speechless
by someone's presence i know you were
really yeah i was blown away yeah the
you i think i counted the number of
times you even mid conversation you were
sort of stopping to take a beat to say
i'm blown away
i'm blown away yeah genuinely like i
i was not bored once i wasn't bored
either i was and i've watched it three
times i'm fascinated yeah his mind is
sharp it is a mind-bending thrill ride
of a labyrinthine
yeah
and what's crazy is that he has seven
millions of fans right
and
we
are now
now he has seven million and two
yeah but i was not familiar with his
work before he came on the show because
you're racist
i'm gonna cut that out
um
but i'm just saying like
it's crazy
that i didn't know about something
that's funny
because
the world revolves around me i'm sorry
but
i mean where am i going with this
how would you have known about him all
you do is watch documentaries about
murderers and uh
legging companies
such a good documentary thank you what's
it called lula rich lula richard a
company called the laurel you would love
it why do i feel like that came and went
like while while the country came and it
everyone watches the same people because
once you finish it you know the
information yeah
huh once you finish documentary you know
about it
sheila doesn't sell leggings
but if she did lularoe's still happening
today lulu
lulu la rolla seen after their grandkids
remember we were in there so pause for
one moment because they're they have
multiple children and two of their
children married each other
[Applause]
i'm not defending like multi-level
marketing devils but they were not
raised in the same house they were like
adults are they simple it's kind of
romantic
no oh
no
wendy thinks her brother's hot oh yeah
he is incredible
that's just narcissism we look alike
that's me just saying i think i'm pretty
do i have self-esteem who knew look i
just feel like the best dating app is
ancestry.com
okay now underrated let's bring it back
because in the interview veer
talks about how
in arrangement he's pro-arranged
marriage because your parents know you
best so are you right
i'm pro-arranged married i'm not any
marriage at this point it depends on who
would set me up you would be horrible at
it i would be great at that really no
you would do it you would do it yeah i
would be you do you would pick somebody
as a bitch
the rest of my life might be married
nobody loves you guys more than me i
look at great partners for everyone but
i verdas so there was a recent
scurfuffle
with vr he he was on last week because
we were we've been touring so this is an
episode we shot last week guys surprise
we bank them oh we're surprised
these are not lively and i used to take
out the parts that might hint to the
fact that we bank them but i'm not doing
that anymore no matter how many times we
change clothes these are bangs
these are not we shot these all one day
in one day
but uh
we've been here for two years yeah
we shot these all two years ago which is
why my fashion is so out of sight
that's why
are you sure
so no uh we uh uh we shot before we went
to uh universal studios
um
benton
that's a different let's open it all for
yourself you've got to say
frustration i need to
really download we'll do that another
time
i don't want to blue ball y'all but
benton at a theme park it is just it
sounds like a pageant mom if there's one
thing i'm good at it's having fun
it is a sight to see that is where i
really come alive i like the one time
i'm not there is the time you go and do
something well you're not fun so um the
point the point is i like to make a
formal complaint about my co-worker
okay i'm right here benton
like loves roller okay i love fun that's
why the person was like we should go
camping we should i'm always like that
but fun is that's not fun to me but you
haven't done it with me you don't know
you didn't think the theme park was
gonna be fun okay but camping and theme
parks those are two very different you
don't know because you're you're
limiting yourself on what is
to allow in the experience ted bundy
camping is a different thing let me just
say that after i've never seen whitney
like this she was speechless i was like
house florida she was like
they should prescribe roller coasters to
everyone we were on our way
and i looked over at whitney and she was
holding the handle like a child like
this and i went whitney and she went
this is fantastic
and would get off the rise and just
stand and she was like
i mean it was kind of sad i was my mind
was blown roller coasters have come a
long way they're amazing i do believe
roller coasters should be prescribed for
depression
it is
a joy well here's the thing is that but
uh in my day
roller coasters they were ratchet at
best uh you know as someone that is an
audio a worry wart like me
um
you used to just sort of hold on a
railing in front of you it was not a
railing it was a part of a shopping cart
it was like a shopping cart handle and
then you would sort of have to like
bounce back and forth in between the
hard back and right right right and you
like may or may not make it if you
didn't make it you definitely came out
with two yeah but that could be fun too
they had to see you least fat to most
fat because they could crush you that's
how i almost died at the fair
that's how least fat the most fat that's
how i gone without my skull crush when i
was a kid
they put us in the in the order the
wrong way and they put a smallest to the
largest
and i was a kid and then the metal bar
was here and then all the weight shifted
this way they pinned my head and i could
hear it cracking and i blacked out and
they didn't stop the ride and my mom was
freaking out but i made it they didn't
stop there they couldn't hear you you're
like stop stop they think you're just
yelling you know for fun
but i made it so that's good for me
anything can be fun if you just submit
to it and you just let it be fun and
that's what i said about astroworld
and
some people had fun so i said about fire
festival okay so some people will ruin
some things and most people have fun
i'm just telling you it's fun we had fun
we could do that a lot of places we
could do it
all i know is that instead
so the key to a theme park trip being
fun is one person's enjoy yeah yeah one
person's in charge and it's good if it's
not you like yes it's not yeah i have
more fun that is the key but also it's
the key you have to group people that
that all kind of want to do the same
thing because if everybody wants to do
something different you have to start
accommodating and that's when people are
like this is probably right
it has to be complete like um it has to
be a dictator
you have to also decide you're going to
have fun i find a little bit of a choice
there's no negotiating there's no i
don't know if i one person is in charge
it's eyes wide shut
there's the dom and then everyone else
yes
you tell me where to go we just have to
start doing more things and seeing if
they're fun camping no
first thing
we did spirit airlines that was fun that
sounds horrible hold on wait the spirit
airlines that was fun did we not have i
felt ready to unpack that
i lost my luggage and i can't unpack it
but did we have fun
no literally you're a liar
okay we flew spirit arrows and we had
fun
you got yelled at by the way someone
keeps in my pocket spirit airlines very
similar to the roller coasters that i
grew up on
that's a great bring back
like they it felt very spiritual
i just want people to comment they'd
like to see us all going to camping trip
well so the point is
uh
beardos jesus christ i forgot is
being interviewed
was a delight the light it is very rare
that i sit down with someone and i'm
i'm not this sounds so narcissistic and
gross but it's like i just
the way he thinks just dazzles
refreshing very refreshing
interview and brain but we didn't finish
the um dc story we didn't he was that we
didn't finish the kerfuffle great that's
what a podcast is we didn't finish
uh tune in next week for more thoughts
my 20s not finishing
so
it's
he
did a performance he wrote a poem i have
a published poem
in a poetry book called young american
poets
where's that book it is at my mom's
house mm-hmm where can i work did it go
anywhere else or did your vlog every
i mean a bunch of other kids got
published it wasn't just me are you the
k mcconaughey of perry kelly a poem of
youth poetry yes if you thought tree was
a competition what was the poetry
poems i associate with being romantic so
911 well then you're really limiting
your viewpoint on poems okay yeah no i'm
promised
um what
and garland why did you have a
angry allen ponies i love it girl and
poe can we get back to our guest who
came graciously gave us his time yeah
and we were talking about his poem and
pre-recorded something back to whatever
we wanted to bring 911 into it
i mean you brought hitler i did bring
hitler into it so i'm to bring up
hiroshima
first of all it's hiroshima
no i won't it's not
yeah it is
[Laughter]
you guys are the history major it's fine
that was it you were a history major
yeah is that why you're always digging
into your ex's past
is that the reason she's a browser
history major
so what was your major
just
we have to google it
at some point you have don't tell me
where
you are
what was your major this like
sometimes i'm stalling because i'm not
i'm completely sure
it was journalism right it's vague what
was yours political science hmm
all right listen viewers got into some
hot water okay i i don't know i did not
major in political science i'm a
journalism
wikipedia also says my dad's name is
vince
and that i'm married to someone named
lance it could be yeah
there's a lot to
process so i uh
bass bass pass back uh
i think
we have to license that
this is like a stream of consciousness
nightmare this is what people want i
think people like this
what people
the ones that listen to this one silly
the ones that the ones that matter the
demo the demographics
i'm starting to understand why better
help is such a consistency
i would love to hear what the inside of
your head is like when you're meditating
it's a
haunted house of uh nightmares and it's
a quarry of
you know
who knows whose head i'd like to be in
verdus
because he's a clear no not in a weird
no
sounding like a weird no no
you know his head i'd like to swallow
not big into the ranged marriages now
huh
i was trying to bring it back to the
guests
i know you're the showrunner but you're
also dressed for the ceremony in the
handmaid's tale so i was a little
confused yeah girl in the striped
pajamas
take a lot of flack from someone that
only wears horse clothes
fair
fair horse girl i don't know you should
try riding horse every now and then uh
rubs your clit i'm having a no not 20 21
by accident so
you are nuts though that's no nut well
no no no
when they don't want to work they're
like i think the wi-fi is down i'm like
it's working for me like it's an
individual computer thing the why when i
don't want to work i just don't bring a
computer yeah i am performing in a
couple cities
uh coming up
coming up we are
per usual
elegant segway
um
into the touch me tour we are
are
um
or do you do that i'm not touching you
which level of immature were you i'm not
touching you
um
so if you want to come see me in person
and see that um
how i'm
the you know like the gauze and cock
that composes my face up close and
personal she's a mummy yeah if you want
to come
if you want to come you want to see what
we put together every night and throw
out on the scene you want us to practice
our coffee guy for you open up in these
cities we pace together
you want to leave something at the altar
um we are uh touring
uh like
wildfire uh i am uh
which will inevitably consume this home
that i overpaid for and can't afford um
i will be
in green bay wisconsin at the meijer
theater november 19th november 20th
we're in minneapolis minnesota
minnesota one little pantagious theater
show sold out second show sell tickets
um december columbus
ohio december 9th 9th
joanne davidson hey girl
i'm coming to your theater uh many more
dates many more dates online sorry i
have uh tourette's um
so we're touring it's a blast i have to
be honest with you i
definitely booked the tour thinking half
of the dates would cancel
um because of kovid and i'm kind of glad
they didn't now all of a sudden you know
we've had some like brutal every show's
like better than the next every show is
better than the next it's like every
time i'm like y'all better be that's
good i'm like i'm like there's pressure
on the audience at this point to be
better than the last one it's but also
like the the performers yeah we're
getting better as well true my mom was
like i read a review in the newspaper
they're doing great what what i don't
know my mom read a review about you in
the wall street journal no i think it
was the washington post oh huh fourth
magazine every show is better than the
next would mean that the shows are
getting worse
every single no every show is every show
is better than the last time
grace is like real life autocorrect like
i have like portrayal energy like people
love that like autographs
you're like in mid-sentence and they're
like there you guys there
you guys grace is german and it shows
yeah so she tried to split us up in
different rooms
and she's like she's like what's she's
like
she's like what's her favorite
and she will never she will never turn
on the air conditioning it's always so
hot
all right too far too far
grace is like what concentration of
juice do you want
what i'm going to edit this tonight this
is so fast and you won't you're going to
want to you're the one that wants to
stop talking about camping yeah she's
like look at this oven look at this oven
mark stop it
i don't cook if you're still listening
honestly i don't get it
but i just want you to know that verdas
is going through uh there was some drama
around him i think it's probably gone
away now because of whatever we just
said right
that's nice of us the whole point of
this open was to
uh cancel ourselves and get backlash so
that weirdos gets a break gets a break
uh now but yes and it doesn't come up if
you do watch it it doesn't come up in
the interview because we did the
interview before
that's right that's right so we
eloquently decided to do this open to
talk about it but yeah so you get it
yeah i mean i don't you know what this
is you're an adult like i don't know you
have a computer yeah yeah what are we
doing what's in a poem and spoken word
oh fucking word is more about like
a lot of that what's floatry floatry is
whenever you
wrap a poem right uh-huh did you hear my
joke i said your period
wait a minute you guys we have to pause
for her going do a poetry
did you hear that joke i said
quiet quiet first let's decide if it's a
joke before you say it laughs i'll let
you know if it was a joke
i'll let you you know if it was a joke
you don't get to decide it's a joke
that's like like on instagram you can
call yourself a model we decide if
you're a model we decide if you get paid
for that feared awesome i can write
whatever i want in my bio furos i love
you and i'm so sorry that this is going
to end our professional and personal
relationship
mind expanding
brilliant so funny he's had four
specials on netflix yep nominated for an
emmy nominated for an emmy um he also
has a d like random because a lot of
people on this um
list in the podcast like the inside
industry right i was talking to fox
about maybe making a television show
about behind the scenes of this podcast
after this day i feel like it's a
dud
idea but um
they're like oh we have something with
him so he might have like a sitcom soon
like i can very much see him being oh
yeah a very big uh
presence like a seinfeld type yeah you
know yeah but so
smart sharp cunning takes risks makes
you think i was i mean i like when i was
uh uh driving to see you uh the other
day in santa monica i had him on spotify
and i was like
i had to like pull over he was like
really making my mind what a mind blows
in a good way it was like it was it made
my mind
calm yeah
i had a brain gasm
oh and that wasn't from reading
the 911 poem
first of all you wish you had a poem
published second of all
did you know that the clitoris is the
path of your palm really benton is
pushing this narrative he's not looking
up benton
i know we all have clitorises but you
don't know the internal parts you google
it whose palm peter dinklage is
i know but that we don't do
generalizations you know i like to go
what do i get
she doesn't science does not do that
what she's saying soon okay um i would
just like to say that please pay
attention
to leave even more leave you know okay
but hey close attention in this
interview because he will never come
back and also if we have any new fans
that revere fans that are coming to
watch him here i'm very sorry please
give us another chance
[Music]
okay we're rolling
look
this podcast is a
controlled plane crash okay um
but not as funny uh and
i have never how many episodes have we
shot
in total 120 115 115 i have never in 150
episodes wanted to play someone's stand
up on the show what whatever you have
like i watch comedians on your podcast
all the time so like
so you know i've never i was listening
over the weekend to you and i was like
first of all
i am intimidated by you why
i'm i'm a sweet brown and you never
happens in a foreign land but your your
mind is just unbelievable
is very kind it is your mind is is your
mind is
a labyrinth of like
limitless brilliance
wow i know can you talk to the press in
india and like michael's call and just
like can you say that exactly on the
phone the way your mind works is
fascinating to me and you are able to
dissect things from so many different
angles and facets completely egoless
and um
you're just a you're
it's very rare that i'm speechless
i will have you call the times of india
immediately after this podcast please
i'm like i'm whitney cummings they're
like you can't say that in this country
your last name your last name is a crime
no we have a billion people somebody's
coming so uh that's
where did i
like this is like this is
this is my problem
is that
watching you you are so we can't say
savage anymore because that was used it
was a pejorative term to describe
indigenous peoples by the colonists of
america
we're like getting rid of language
faster than we're creating it like i
don't know what i'm called anymore in
the states like i used to be like
south
pacific asian islander you're just
hired
you are employed that's why i'm here
yeah what is it
what is what like what yeah
what i don't know i genuinely that's
fascinating because i'm
you can't say
asian although i am asian and people
don't say indian because there's like
history why can't we say
asian because it's it's not i'm just
i think in the american context perhaps
asian means like east asian or southeast
asia but it also is like asian is kind
of an odd
thing to describe because there's so
many different kinds of asia like
japanese and chinese cultures are so
radically different to just go that's
asian it's like no it's japanese or
chinese like very different i think it's
more about like the just call me doctor
like you're you're safe you're calling
me your main doctor
call me smarter than you
if you see an indian ground this you
just be like doctor it's good to meet
you and you'll be like you're damn right
my rheumatologist swami ventura love you
his his his first name is swami
s-w-a-m-y
that's like a guru name like that what
does it tell me swami i think means guru
like god man guru or like uh
holy or something if you
it means religious teacher there you go
by the way okay can i say this if you d
if you tell me that my
rheumatologist is a con man i'm i'm it
will break my heart okay so firstly like
like indian guys who nobody wants to
sleep with in the first place back home
come here and like start sexual
revolutions and it's the strangest
fucking thing i've ever seen like every
cult leader is is in it yes so the next
time just call us and we'll tell you
about the guy
you know just like stop listening to
guys who come over and do basic indian
shit but what that is so funny like if
an indie guy just comes over and it's
like sit and cross your legs it's like
oh i'll ride you all night long if you
can start a cult
i i was talking to somebody i think it's
the sitar you know the sitar in the
background
like anything sounds spiritual if you
just put that shit behind it like if
you're like empty or wallets and they're
like yes because there's
just tell a woman
she can sit down and it counts as
exercise
yoga it's like yoga they were like just
lie down and breathe and take a nap i'm
like i love you like i saw that that
bikram documentary amazing right but
really all he did was like turn the heat
up right like that's like like that guy
just fucked with air conditioning
otherwise that's just yoga by the way
the bikram yoga thing was so big i
remember the first time i did it before
i knew anything about anything and i was
very susceptible to a cult or anything
that would make me like skinny or feel
better about myself or whatever and i
went and it was carpeted because it's
too dangerous that he turns the heat up
to or the bikram yoga is like 130
degrees or something and it's steam
so you can't have it be on wood or
you'll fall because you're doing all
these precarious poses like people are
passing out and stuff there's a carpet
so it was carpeted and it smelled like
mold and i was like this is just moldy
like it was i remember just going like
this is because the precipitation from
the steam would go into the carpet and
it was just a moldy yolk cloth i was
like anything that benefits you're
getting from this yoga are being undone
by the black mold you're inhaling i just
picture him like calling people in his
family on the weekend back home he's
like you're never gonna believe what i
make these americans do
and they pay me every week for it that
is the idea like they're doing this
they're doing reverse warriors they
don't want an ac like
they're fine with like a shitty carpet
uh it's yeah dude if yoga is a prank
that is so funny like a 5 000 year old
prank
the idea that someone's like okay it's 7
a.m wake up drive to my studio
lie down and suffer on my turn what you
were just doing in your bed i want you
to do in my space
and pay me yeah but now you get like i
got yoga is a thing yes and like bill
yoga is a thing instagram yeah but i'm
like not patriotic at all like so i'm
like everybody do your thing i love
everyone you you wanna
i think bastardize is the word it's fine
so i i hold no like allegiance to yoga
or indian culture but when i heard like
goat yoga i'm like fuck you guys like
that's too much like that's
that like you cross the line i'm a
family that's just respectful yeah why
is there goat why
why is it shitting yeah on this practice
like as a man who's never done yoga i
was still like no preserve it without
the goat like the goat is too much for
me is that so that's not a thing in
india no everybody does yoga just not
with goats goats are around but they're
just
they're not
participating you guys came up with the
goats like we did nothing with goats
ever but eat them like that's all we've
ever done with the goat is eat the goat
that is so wild and you just reminded me
one of my best friends in college was um
named
yogita yeah
is that a that's how she pronounced it
yeah yogitta's is yeah that's right but
what does that i never
is it like what is that relationship now
i need you to like decode every name
bewitched enchanted is what that means
let's do this like you ask me about like
indian names and i'll be like what's
susan what is susan
what is the mythology susan is
desperately seeking
that's what that means
i can do this all day long
annie
is someone in a hall nice yeah
with a director who anyway don't even
get me started on that hack um so i
i'm just gonna say this because if i
don't say it it won't
it won't have been said
nice
profound
um i'm very overwhelmed by you because
there's so much i want to ask you
there's about
i want to ask you more about life stuff
philosophical stuff you have
how many specials do you have uh
full
four stand-up specials
there's so much content of you being
brilliant i don't want to make you do it
here because i believe that on podcasts
like this that people are in the
wormhole of you and i don't want you to
repeat yourself i'm so obsessed with
your mind and the way you think i just
want to ask you some things that you
probably normally wouldn't necessarily
get asked and um
i don't want to
like waste this time that's how excited
i am for you to be here but i do want to
talk about acting okay
because after being a
hugely famous comedian
uh i'm sorry before being a hugely
famous comedian you studied and trained
as an actor i did yeah
can we just mentally masturbate on this
for a second okay you trained like
straussberg like
method
why is this a society
don't we train everyone in acting
so that everyone can act like they're
a good person
well if you consider the world
performing our own lives anyway in some
version of that like that's what
instagram is isn't it aren't you
performing your own life like you're not
living it as such that's curating for
sure and acting when the camera's on but
i i do believe so as someone i
acting is important and this isn't just
a podcast you know for actors if people
right now are like i you know
do this other job and acting doesn't
apply to me i think it does i think it
applies to everyone you know we tell an
average of 30 lies a day yeah acting and
we act all day all the time in the form
of lying but i'm just fascinated by the
concept of like acting like
number one what does it say about our
human nature that we love to be conned
why do we pay money to go see someone
act because okay so i had a
in the the stanislavski school there was
a russian like artistic director and so
i i did like drama school in the states
right in like galesburg illinois which
was a lot of
like american drama teachers just kind
of going like him out with your
shoulders and take a new direction and
you know that stuff and then after like
three years and a lot of money this one
russian was like acting is very simple
just read script believe script and then
do what the fuck you like right and i
was like i just spent like a hundred
grand on on college and then i don't
have time to train you i'm hacking
american democracy
but i think it's because we don't
believe the script like when's the last
time you read something or heard
something and without a shadow of a
doubt you believed it 100
like you could count it on one hand the
amount of times this last week you read
or saw something and you were like
that's absolutely true
if you think about it
so i think that's why
you know acting training for like
regular human beings because we just
don't believe the script of anything
anything that we see anymore we live in
like a performative in fact i think yes
and i mean this is like what john
beaujouri
like kind of predicted the french
philosopher about the simulacrum like
you know it's
in fact if i see something written out
now i go
that can't be true because why would you
you know it's almost it's almost like
we've trained to believe if i see it on
the internet it must not be true if i
see it you know like i need to check
that and corroborate if it's so fucked
up that it doesn't surprise me it's
probably true to me like that's how i
feel about it like you know sometimes
i'll be like you know oh yeah that's
it's so evil it has to be true but
i'm you know what i say i don't even say
it's true i go i go that tracks
that tracks that tracks that feels very
los angeles i don't know why here's why
that's a writer's room phrase of like is
the story tracking like does it make
sense so
you know veer comes over
i we walk around the house and then we
get him a coffee uh i say oh what kind
of coffee do you want and then someone
five minutes later comes in with a
coffee that tracks because he ordered it
you know it's like a plus b equals c
i have two la things that make no sense
to me one is okay so a i think in and
you're very successful so i'm you have
many people working for you so you have
an assistant with you all right uh i
feel like la people get an assistant
like eight years before they need in the
system all right so that's one
okay
and i'm sure you deserve yours
right uh but i think there are a lot of
assistants out there who are like i am
at the same level as this person i don't
need this job that's one
like you wait you need me to drive you
there you don't have a car i have a car
i'm driving you because you don't
because you don't have a car and i do i
feel like yeah i'm doing better than you
are this is my assistant who sleeps in
my bed uh
or like in the room next door i stay
with my assistant's parents yeah
and then love that yeah love that as a
very ellie love that like love him love
her love that and they are also so past
that have no capacity for empathy and
have don't know what love is yeah and
it's usually like
suits right so agents
they probably do love it
they're incapable of self-love or love
of another human being
you should ask them how much like that
should be a thing like love that how
much how much and then just wait do you
love it
what's your definition of love quantify
it like i would just be like yeah like
if that's your definition of love we
have a problem it is hard because in
general that is a
symptom of the greater i think
vernacular disease of
you know we've overused words to the
point of them being meaningless you know
love is meaningless now and i mean i did
i don't want to be a um
do a bad impression of myself but and i
think it was the my second special i did
the uh when love when you're in a
relationship it starts to become yeah uh
i love you it basically just means calm
down at a certain
point
i'm sorry
it means i'm sorry i love you love you
it means fuck you after a while you know
it means a lot of things and um
but yeah the value of words is not
something that um california values uh
the way they should like brilliant
genius i know louis ck did all those two
hilarious hysterical yeah everything is
awesome
how do you say something's good anymore
without
like i have to be like you're a
brilliant genius amazing incredible
isn't everything fire like isn't that
just what like your file this is file
everything's fire by the way we're in a
fire zone we have wildfires i'm
triggered um
and uh and
you know what's interesting the wait
what was the one that i was just gonna
say about oh genius everything's genius
it's like was that in-n-out burger
genius
i went in and out book just by the way
because everybody was like you have to
go you have to go and i was like
yeah you don't yeah
if you're gonna eat my god uh it should
be tastier
like you know like at least if you're
gonna murder my god it should be tasty
that's how i feel about it in and out is
wildly overrated i do not understand but
you have to take that with a grain of
salt like people that live here are kind
of masochistic so if they're like i love
in and out it's like yeah because you
normally eat hemp seed granola
of course in and out it's gonna be
delicious remember the days when like
americans went to the east to do drugs
remember those days like to find
yourself and that was a big thing right
yeah you pray love
did she do drugs and he'd pray love no
but he'd pray love snort inhale
eat snort
fuck i don't know i okay so i actually
have seen that movie twice on like two
separate dates and it is not a bad movie
like i feel like it got shat on a lot
because it was a little like
white savory i believe is what
the word is but i actually like the
movie i thought it was nice um i
have such hot takes on movies like and
it's gonna ruin my career
that i'm gonna pass on this okay but i
think more
that
the that book i just could take or leave
i don't have any feelings for it but
elizabeth gilbert who wrote that book
wrote a follow-up book uh called
committed and she went all around the
world and interviewed people about what
commitment and love means in every
culture the definition of love in every
culture and it changed my life
hasn't changed your perception of love
um
yes yes because in the concept of love
uh
is very
western like it's very the concept of
like you know we have to be in love all
the time like you know this idea that we
constantly have to be in this you know
on this cloud in this utopia with this
like quixotic like constant passion and
relentless monogamy and spark
of you know a lot of cultures like it's
kind of a business deal you know
and in some cultures it's like the men
live here the women live here and some
it's like yeah we get we love each other
but then it dies off at some point and
then it's kind of a business deal and
like he can have wives other places like
it's just about sort of what
quote-unquote love looks like in
different cultures and how americans are
is specifically masochistic in terms of
how
wildly dissonant it is
the expectations are for love given our
biological and neurological limitations
i don't know like
i feel like
this is just me but i think love is the
ability to be completely yourself
relative to somebody else
that's cool that's a really cool
definition you know like
that 10 seconds when you're like lying
in the dark before you fall asleep with
somebody if you are entirely yourself in
that moment relative to that person i
think that's like you're just there
jerking off yeah
yeah yeah yeah like individually
like a super cat you guys could just be
you've done i could just jerk off alone
the light from your ipad is distracting
me put it off and here's what i'll say
i
i think as an addendum to that
and be complete yourself and as you grow
and evolve and change you get to
continue you get to be different people
as you grow and evolve and change yeah
they know my thoughts on self-love like
this is a big american thing where i'm
like
uh i do a bit i'm sorry but like i'm
like people who love themselves have low
standards because that's easy
that is so funny that is so funny but
it's like you know everybody's about
self only when you love yourself can you
love somebody else is the the allegation
i mean
i know isn't loathing good for love like
isn't
right self-loathing you're gonna get
along
see now i feel like a narcissist because
i was like you're a genius you're
brilliant and then you're saying all
these things that i agree with he's a
comic right he hates himself
he's such a genius that's what i say
um so i agree i think that i think love
is a very vague term and the word
self-love is very immature like it's
just immature it's too vague it doesn't
really it's just kind of meaningless if
i if you will it's like let's go to the
buffet of what
what's the food that doesn't tell me
what kind of food i'm signing up for
like that is but it's just sort of a
vague
nothingness that uh we've had this
pavlovian reaction to like be like yeah
like it's just a cue
um i feel like it's everybody's just
going i'm okay
being by myself even though this isn't
ideal like i i feel like it's that too
as well like you know i'm i'm okay with
my loneliness is is disguised as
self-love or is termed as self-love yes
okay yeah oh yeah exactly or you're just
awful and no one fucks with you because
you're a monster
who loves them you know what i'm saying
exactly i think a lot of people conflate
self-love with arrogance and egomania i
think a lot of people
um
self-love is but i think a big part of
self-love is being able whatever that
means is being able to go like
you need to apologize you shouldn't have
done that you shouldn't have said that
that wasn't okay that wasn't appropriate
you're being jealous like part of
self-love is critiquing yourself it's
not radical self-acceptance oh you mean
like saying that to yourself it's not
saying that to somebody else
because that too could be self-love
right like you you need to apologize to
me i'm setting boundaries because i love
myself i don't know that's that's just
that you can
you can do that if you want yeah i just
don't think that that's gonna get you
the result i don't think you can if you
have to tell someone apologize to me
you're the crazy one listen i'm why are
you even engaging with that it's been 30
years since i got an apology from anyone
like that was my last apology your dad
went no just somebody who beat me up in
boarding school but no that was my last
apology and i've accepted that the
universe does not send apology will you
stay with me when you come here from now
on absolutely i am obsessed with you
thank you you're just a beast okay so i
think that self-love i think there's
like an instagram it's very cool right
now to be like self-love i love myself
it's all vegan sort of silly and i'm
probably being overly analytical and
overthinking it um and like persnickety
but
you know i think that
you know
that radical self-acceptance physically
on the outside a plus great thumbs up
yeah you know unless you're unhealthy or
hurting yourself or in whatever way um
but
there's i don't like this thing that's
like because you're basically saying i'm
i'm done i'm cooked i'm perfect just the
way i am yeah mentally emotionally
i have a
feeling there's a little more of the to
be chiseled
i have a like in the da vinci
masterpiece that you are i have a
feeling that we're halfway to the david
perhaps the fact that there's nobody
within a 20-foot radius of you right now
might be a barometer for the fact that
your common denominator is you and all
these people that don't want to be
around you well i just i love myself and
this so i i just like to say just
respect yourself
is a little bit
better of a word i don't like self-love
i just think of masturbating
true
yeah which is something you don't see a
lot of at a therapist but i'm a big work
comics so we're a word
we have to pick the right words so i
would say instead of like self-love or i
love myself it's like i prioritize
myself i prioritize self-care i respect
myself self-love just seems childish i
also think it's
like i was thinking about this the other
day like you guys stay with your parents
for like such a short amount of time in
america the minute you're like 16 to 18
you're out right and then
it's like if you're by the way
i mean
a lot of our parents didn't even want us
to come into the world and were forced
to have us right because we can't they
couldn't abort us but then we guys end
up staying with our parents till we're
like sometimes 30 35 right like emily i
would love that
emily goes home to visit her parents
like every other weekend so but then not
toxic you don't have space for self-love
or self-exploration when you're just in
a house taking care of each other's
needs cleaning later right exactly like
indian parents invest in future
employees like they don't raise kids
right they're just like you fucking
you're 20 now i need this this this and
this fucking go to work right now i
raised you you're alive now you work for
me uh what i mean i just i guess i
wanted to avoid asking about you know
the the culture shock when you come to
america like the differences in roasting
because i figure you have to do it so
much but what is like
has anything
new come along that you notice that's
like like not something that you've
already sort of discussed and picked
apart in terms of america's well by the
way it's it's changing a lot like every
time i used to come over here and
you gig with so many comics i'm sure you
you're used to like the the comic from
abroad who's like hey life here is so
different and you know life's kind of
simple where i'm from and america is
kind of complicated and you know like i
went to college in galesburg illinois
that's where i went to college is that
nor is that near chicago yeah it's it's
three hours out right so this is
the mecca of civilization as we know it
yeah
yeah right so like one kmart one jc
penny right and and i'm given
or as we say pennies yeah
pennies where's the pennies is it j.c
penney zu penny the pennies ah it's jc
penney
but in the south they say pennies okay
we just call it pennies so like i'm
given host parents right my mom i just
made you dumber did you see that you did
yeah
i don't know if they're gonna let me
back in so sorry your iq just went down
uh my host mom was a lady called pinky
gibbons pinky yeah and and she was just
an american lady who was a cafeteria
lady and my host dad was jean the
trucker
right g-e-n-e yeah and so like drove a
big rig and
that's as american as you get right like
real america to me that like who i am
the fact that i was indian was as
strange as the fact that i wanted to be
a thespian
does that make sense interesting you
know so it wasn't a cultural thing it
wasn't an america thing it was just
you're this thing that we don't
understand now let's have meatloaf and
do the dishes yeah and i think at some
level that's america as well is wake up
at 5 00 a.m clean your house pay your
bills be safe go to bed and i feel like
that picture of you guys gets lost a lot
in like the noise
you know interesting yeah i i
i travel so much that
i feel like you know as a comedian
obviously all we do is travel it's like
there's so many
americas
and and i have not extensively traveled
the you know east to be able to be an
authority on this but the same way
france is super different than italy is
super different than
germany like to me that's states in
america the states in america to me are
as different as countries are in europe
i think so i've i wore like japan and
china it's like i would pick a state in
america over france any day
that's one of the beyond
any state i
want to talk about france okay so notre
dame burned down to be clear
i
love
architecture okay
and i value the people that built it i
respect i care i love beautiful things i
love
god
whatever that means to you i mean no
disrespect
that being said i need to interrupt you
are you just trying to remember
everything that's connected to notre
dame right now and saying you love it
like it's you're like okay i'm just i'm
god it's a building i'm stalling i'm
stalling stalling no i'm just i want to
preface this by saying i'm not like a
fuck sacred things person sure you know
what i'm saying i know the value of
sacred things and rituals and and stones
mean things and i have special rocks i
have my little
touring rock like i know i
i anthropomorphize
you know
very inanimate objects so that said
i just want you to know this isn't just
me being
crazy old me
emily what what was the issue because
i'm going to just pull up my tweet
it was
this is not the time for you to tell
everyone you went to notre dame as soon
as notre dame burned down
everyone posted photos of themselves in
front of notre dame like a good notre
dame like a full notre dame not the
burnt down no one was inside which means
no one waited in line to actually go in
the building
and can you imagine
just think about as soon as the sacred
building burns down people are just like
honey what month did we go swipe
they're swiping through their photos i
mean those photos were up within minutes
people are just like okay was it july 20
20 2018 or 19 or 19. where do you have
the phone where's the iphoto get to get
that on the drive it's on the other
drive like getting the perfect photo of
them at notre dame to be like god i love
notre dame like you didn't wait in line
you didn't go in
why are you making this about your trip
to europe that's like if a celebrity
dies
and then everybody posts photos with
that celebrity and then the celebrity
lives you know like at the end of it
like that's what that is
right that is so funny
it would to me it just turned you've
gone too soon gone too soon and then
like two days later he's like oh this is
just how did you turn this this the fire
of a sacred place into bragging about
your vacation just like every agent a
manager and lawyer in los angeles trying
to pull up their paris vacation photo
that they were too embarrassed to post
before because going to notre dame was
dorky
as soon as it caught on fire it was cool
and reverent but before a burn down it
was like you're notre dam cool dork like
what kind of dork visits a church on
their vacation that actually is like the
uncoolest thing you can post from paris
it is like the the you know the notre
dame unless it burns down yeah
so everyone's like i never got to post
that banger selfie in front of notre
dame it burned down here's my shot after
this podcast's influencers are going to
be like what burnt down that is where
i'm going next which monuments have
burnt down
there was a
they had to shut down or gate off
chernobyl because after the show came
out so many influencers were trying to
take selfies at chernobyl oh
yeah uh we had that same thing happen
after uh so we had these terror attacks
and
hotel mumbai was a movie that uh
army hammer was in who we have since
learned is uh
and people were just going and taking
selfies with like bullet holes
uh you know in these cafes during that
shootout
and uh what is the face you make with
the bullet hole is it i don't know it's
a strange neck
you know like a face i'm sorry
like i don't know like is it a
what is it can i tell you that's my
ideal life like i just want to be an
influencer that's what i want to be okay
if i could just quit all of this and
just get paid to go places and post
about it on instagram i would do that
shit in a heartbeat for like five months
but i would do that shit in a heartbeat
i just want to know what that feels like
the journal of family care
uh family medicine and primary care in
india found that 259
people worldwide died
in 130
selfie related incidents between 2011
and 2017
compared to just 50 people who were
killed by sharks
a new survey found that 41 of us have
already risked our safety in pursuit of
a selfie
i want to know like
how many of the people in the selfie
have been murdered by other people in
the selfie like because that also counts
as one of these deaths because
women that are murdered or murdered by
their spouses so
a lot of the selfies with your husband
could you be you're taking a picture
with your murderer future murderer
this is like i
in your country like crime is
entertainment like that's another thing
that i've never been able to understand
like true crime like i don't understand
the obsession i watch it we love it
yeah but how good is your life when your
crime is also content
is a question to ask
when people want to talk about you
when you're not famous and dead so crime
is entertainment is that's not a common
that's not a global
um that's not globally fun to enjoy
watching people get murdered no i don't
think so because i think your volumes
are quite low of murder
you know when it's like if it's like one
lady in the forest that's maybe
watchable but if it's like 5000 people
in a state maybe not watchable so what
is that what does that say what what's
the what's the
takeaway on that because i think
for i think i know why neurologically we
love true crime yeah um we you know are
wired to want to you know csi all these
sh i mean it's it's wild to me that
anyone wants to have any conversation
about like you can't say this as a
comedian you can't say this which that
whole cancer culture thing is obviously
wildly overblown and not even an
interesting conversation
but
it's like oh you can't say this you
can't say slut you can't say whore that
you can't say white trash you can't say
this and that it's like watch csi every
episode is about a dead hooker or a dead
prostitute and they're just like in the
semen inside the vagina it's like if
it's drama you can say whatever you want
and then but as soon as it's comedy
that's when things get done i think it's
something to aspire to
when when
crime seems out of the ordinary or it
seems abnormal to you then your culture
is in a good place
like if it's just so every day that
you're desensitized to it and it's not
watchable or even entertainment then
you're not in a good place so like the
fact that something seems horrific
enough to want to watch it like says
good things about your culture like as a
barometer because it means it's rare it
means it's red so
i mean there are countries where you
wake up and
like that's minor compared to what
communities are going through like what
larger people uh you know when someone
dies it's an event that's a good sign
yeah i think so and they make a
documentary about it and a movie and a
spin-off
and you want to talk to people about it
and you want to hear how it happened
because that's really what you want to
hear right is how it happened and why it
happened because it seems so strange to
you
so i think you should be proud of the
fact that it seems strange strange
because it's not to you or it's not a
fair portion of like i grew up in
nigeria and in india so i grew up in
africa and in india and no we're very
desensitized to violence we're very
desensitized to crime at some level so
yeah
wild okay i'm overloaded with questions
now now i'm overwhelmed so
can i ask you
like what did you what have you learned
about human nature that is what are what
how are we alike
i think people always want to go how are
these things different how are we alike
africa india america what
is similar
in the human nature that you have seen
i think that
of dicks
yeah and also
what we're told what to believe
and i think more so now than ever before
you know
we
for all the things that we lack in our
daily life or our family life etc we
fill those with beliefs that we're told
to have
and in africa or in india sometimes it's
by politicians and within america it's
by conglomerates and by like social
media etc but
we're okay to believe things that we're
told to believe
and that brings brings me back to the
question um about
the acting thing of like our inherent
desire to be conned yeah our inherent
desire to be just told what to do just
tell me just let me give me some rules
to follow so i can follow it i don't
want to be a leader i want to be a
follower just just i don't care what the
rules are just tell me what to do
tell me what to believe
and and also
let me feel like i'm a part of something
like the tribalism that comes with that
because that comes with safety and
security if i'm a part of this you know
i don't okay we're gonna go kill that
person fine if we're gonna go kill those
people because they're that color that
means you're not gonna kill me i feel
safe i think that's where we live now is
beliefs used to be ten percent of your
human experience you know political
beliefs or world beliefs and now they
are forty percent of your human
experience
all of us
okay so
you're a nightmare how do you live with
your brain are you okay yeah i'm fine i
just feel like just another
self-loathing comedian you're not i mean
we can deprecate but like is your mind
a haunted house of because i think
there's a certain level of intelligence
that's actually
inhumane for someone to have
no i
because you're able to break things down
from a very kind of i don't think meta
is the word and i think facebook just
took that
you know name uh that word to rename
their service but like
you're so able to deconstruct things and
analyze things and see things from so
many different sides sometimes
when people have that
they're
kind of um
emotionally homeless in a way you know
because they don't they're like
no i can relate to that i feel empty
absolutely i can relate to feeling
homeless in terms of and that's kind of
the trip that i'm on right now uh
so i
i sold my house in mumbai two months ago
i sold everything that i owned in the
last 10 years i have a weird question
okay can we look up your house on the
internet that you sold uh you won't find
it really it's it's it's a flag like
it's an apartment in mumbai
we don't have to put on the show i just
i love
zillowing and redfin housing
houses googling what where is my it's
like my pornography i i can like guys
want to watch like like bang bus i just
want to like look at the inside of
people's houses
i'm going to pretend like i haven't
watched bang bass right now
is the thing um
i'm i'm on i'm going across the world
without checking luggage that's my
mission for the next year and a half of
my life so i'm like i have eight
t-shirts two pairs of pants two sweaters
um and i'm just traveling for a year and
a half
so
it's pretentious to call this minimalism
because it's not and i'm well to do um
so like privileged essentialism i guess
is the way to put it but the rules are
um
spend any amount of money on travel on
hospitality
on experience it means like tipping
like hotels fly first stay in a suite
eat in a nice restaurant get front row
seats but i'm not buying jeans i'm not
shopping i'm not doing any of that shit
i just have two bags and they'll go
across are you washing your jeans then
you do have
i have two so
once a month maybe they get washed i'm
sorry okay so okay hold on
this is a big thing
men that don't wash their jeans okay so
you have one pair i don't care how much
they cost or how many pairs you have but
you do have to wash them
do you though yes do you have to wash
your jeans yes
you have to wash your jeans because you
sit on the subway you sit in a cab you
sit in an uber and you come in you sit
on my couch
you're bringing
like
a
airport into my home well these have
been washed this year i promise you
thank you
it's the variant in your back pocket it
it is absolutely right
spreads through ass cracks and then
that's how that happens
you know all this mask stuff you guys
are right america you don't need that
vaccine what you will need is is washed
jeans that's what's going to fix us
clean your leave eyes forget holes in
our shirts so you can put a needle
through it and vaccinate it can i tell
you something i'm fucking quadruple
waxed i want to i just want to vent
about this like i took a vaccine in
india which is very good you're addicted
to the vaccine yeah absolutely
and and america wouldn't recognize that
vaccine so i had to take two pfizers on
top of that i've mixed vaccines this is
wild i know i'm like this just this
feels uh
i've seen with another one like i was
just venting
yeah i have full vaccines in me
now you're just bragging right there's
new money new money problems this is
like this is how we will look at you
with your your vaccine privileges
netflix specials three vaccines ladies
and gentlemen check privilege check i i
love this about america as well you're
always checking each other's privilege
like that's a great thing is it
no did i just do it wait did i no you
didn't but
okay you have barometers to measure what
your privilege is
got it right yes so when you talk about
whether it's punch up punch down
people etc etc which one can we just
like sorry i like to kind of just
like walk people through
things that sometimes we take for
granted that some i know i think more
things are inside baseball than actually
are yeah punching up and punching down
is like
is like if you're in a
position of power are you making jokes
about someone beneath you or above you i
just feel like that's always so
subjective that i my brain gets confused
yeah and also i don't think you define
your power as people define your power
you know like if you if you ask me and
if and i've actually put this out on my
twitter i put it out like
three months twitter that has seven
point seven million followers yeah i'm
also indian so you just like just said
there's a billion that's me there's a
billion dollars you get followers easier
it's just what does that mean
it's like you your twitter is like a toy
shop and my twitter's toys r us right
it's just like there's a bigger
you know this is more toys uh there's
more people to follow me and they
but that doesn't
okay thank you i feel a little bit
better i hate myself slightly less but
also like what does that mean that means
that like they spread the word faster or
everyone's hanging out or there's one
more counts being in my
kate i wouldn't it be like
yeah i could make the argument that it
would be the opposite like we all have
one twitter account for the house
eight people one account
you know what i mean and then you just
put it up like put a phone on a wall and
you all come and look at it every now
and then you have 7.7 million on twitter
that means you probably have so many
other people that are in the house with
them looking at those yeah um
i put out a question just saying what do
you exemplify is western privilege right
and so like to me what i think western
privilege is is it's the ability to go
anywhere on an american passport you can
travel like the world without visas and
stuff
most people just said you drink from the
tap
like in america so it's not your
military it's not your celebrity it's
not your economy just you drink like
your tap water is safe and it's like a
strangely small thing unless you're in
you're you're in flint michigan or west
virginia fuck i've been drinking from
the tap everywhere i go is that a bad
thing should i not do that
from the tap a lot so when i lived in
virginia i drank out of a hose so i was
15. you drank out of like a hose you
know but that was
that i in the water was like sweet
in west virginia there's a lot of um
there's what i like to say and this
didn't get me in trouble
cool can't wait
um
basically there's lots of like
third worlds within america yeah
within this
quote first world or country right so i
mean our literacy rates are pretty it's
pretty brutal yeah there's this amazing
documentary called uh dark water which
um we talked about the other day emily
with mark ruffalo about the dupont the
poisoning of the corporate poisoning of
the water in west virginia and uh
the carcinogens and so the chemical
plants and so american corporations have
um strategically poisoned
the water supply of the people they
value the least
in our country so there are parts
of america where i would say do not
drink the water because a lot of the
people that i went to school with
um and you know west virginia the dupont
spell they have like
you know
deformities and extra fingers and all
kinds of things
i
i've just not carried a water bottle
around with me for most of my life that
i can't get used to doing it like
wearing a water bottle yeah like isn't
that a very like that's an la thing it's
also a mumbai thing now where everybody
just has their own personal little glass
yeah and like with a straw like a
plastic straw like a collapsible straw
something i just can't do it plastic
straw plastic straw at this point i feel
like you might as well just say the
n-word
is is yeah not as bad not emily just
quit
i said yeah i just love what she did
right now she's like just the just the
self-righteous indignation when people
like a plastic straw
you know but and then they're wearing
the paper mask it's like well the masks
are the worst thing now for the ocean
right all the masks that are you know
all the turtles are running around with
little masks on in the ocean i've never
seen a turtle with a mask on like that's
not a thing that is not a thing i'm
sorry did you not have teenage mutant
ninja turtles i did none of them had
masks on them
absolutely i've never seen an n95
fucking turtle in in the ocean like
that's not a thing this is new this is
new
this is new
i will find it i will pay money to see
jones.com right now and i will find it
that's just somebody put a mosque on a
table like that that's just a bad pet
owner that's not an environmental status
we're now taking a break
from whitney and verdas having a
hilarious conversation a small brain
small break teeny tiny tiny boy braids
tiny break from theater dots here we go
welcome to ads without whitney
[Laughter]
all right here we are finally she's gone
i know if we're going to try to do these
ads without whitney because
we can't find her so
we're going to do our best to do them
without her but don't worry sponsors
she's still in them we have
secret yes backstage video
we have content exclusively from the
road yes of her using the products all
over because we don't just talk the talk
we walk the walk speaking of walking
didn't you get catch whitney in the
airport doing some silly walking
oh yeah wouldn't he does this thing
where in every airport she needs to
stretch because planes like tear you up
or something i don't really know the as
a professional athlete i'm not really
sure why she does it but yeah i did
catch her doing some questionable
activity in the airport that i think
requires the need of our sponsor better
help well let's take a look it's her
it's his lunches ma'am
i noticed that you're being insane in
public would you like to um use our code
for better health
i just wanted to know because you can
you can use it from anywhere at any time
you could log in right now i'm being
insane and get help for whatever you're
doing about this insane this is healthy
stretching is healthy do you think do
you think these people agree with you
okay but once last time you and emily
stretched your body it's called
self-care i do it when i go you know
places where you're both destroyed
self-respect the gym it's because i go
to therapy and i know if i don't take
care of myself
i can't you'll force everyone else to
watch you do it i can't take care of
anybody else okay i'm setting a good
example i want you to know that right
now you can log in on that little phone
device and talk to someone a
professional counselor to help you while
i'm exercising a professional if i
facetime my counselor
we even had a guy at the show
who was a therapist last night who said
he uses better help
yeah you should took that advice what
more do you mean you won't he also told
you that while you were doing yoga on
stage i was do i was stretching at the
same time i was doing the meet and
greets it's called multitasking that's
called mental health it's called mental
illness it's called mental and physical
health betterhelp.com you need to go to
better health to learn to calibrate your
tone you need to go to better manners
goodbye
well it's good to know you guys talk
badly about me while you're on the road
it's not bad to say you need to stretch
okay that's what she's doing though in
the airport she's literally just
lounging she's lunging around people
those people are trying to get their
luggage eat tuna sandwiches and she's
just lunging in circles who's eating
tuna sandwiches and many people in
airports yeah they should be on a no-fly
list egg salad sandwiches are sold
readily no fly list
better help it's more affordable than
traditional offline counseling and
financial aid is available it's
available all you like this line it's
not self-help it's professional
counseling which she clearly needed in
that time done securely online the
service is available for clients
worldwide so any airport in america any
airport this podcast is sponsored by
betterhelp and good for you listeners
get 10 off their first month at
betterhelp.com
whitney please help whitney by going to
betterhelp.com whitney find her in your
local airport did you brush your teeth
this morning every morning look at my
teeth that's the best thing about me
oh i think your attitude's your best
thing thank you
you know why because i got a better help
oh
wrong ad but
um yes i did brush my teeth this morning
and i used my most favorite device your
equipped toothbrush my quip
let me say on the road we were on the
road this weekend and when you you know
we bring ours everywhere brittany
whitney lilly brings her to the venue
with her yeah for on the on the go
brushing right and um i did
uh i did want to see if this was a new
thing she was doing just because she has
these ads now right and i'm like are you
just using are you just brushing your
teeth all of a sudden right right right
you know and you've had this shitty
mouth your whole life and now you're
just brushing your teeth for these ad
money right so we were at a show and her
middle school best friend was there so i
did some investigation all right well
let's take a look let's take a look at
this video okay your whitney's best
friend from middle school slash high
school and i just want to know has she
always brushed her teeth
because she has a dirty mouth now but do
you think that she's like are you
talking verbally
well i used to do sleepovers at your
house yeah
because she's big on dental hygiene now
aren't you i don't i have not brushed my
teeth uh
oh do you want to grab your equipped
toothbrush and go ahead and do that real
quick
where is it oh i thought you stole it i
would never steal that i have my own
this is actually the most amazing
toothbrush it really is look
you can travel with it this sticks to
the wall it charges
and then it vibrates it gets a gentle
vibration to give you the best clean
without damaging your gum
isn't that crazy is that a great it
vibrates so it just does it so that you
don't have to yeah and it doesn't damage
your gums you don't have to brush too
hard also can it fully exfoliate your
skin so when you have a dirty amount you
can fix it right up look at this but you
and you can stick it to the wall look at
how you can and then stick in your
bathroom shower if you're a shower brush
and then it's hygienic so you're not
going to create the next coved variant
you can travel with it you need to do
science experiments
it doubles as a it looks like the rose
that was some hard-hitting journalism i
know i'm a journalist
toothbrushes you are and you cracked the
case i did we know that it's genuine you
gotta brush your teeth all the time
people and the quip electric toothbrush
is loved by over seven million mouths
almost as many as us
the timed sonic vibrations with 30
second pulses to guide a dentist's
recommended two-minute clean it's a
lightweight and sleek design for adults
and kids with no wires or bulky charger
to weigh you down it really is a very
sleek design really travel anywhere it's
so easy to travel with and i love it
like sticks to stuff so yeah it's always
in read yeah and then you don't just
like wrap your toothbrush head up i
really do think everyone should have one
because you know the vibrations like
it's softer it cleans your teeth with
all the abrasion and damage to your gums
and i have a fear of having receding
gums do you have that no i have great
gums well they could recede if you're
brushing them too hard but you're not
because you got your quip right and if
you go to get quip dot com slash whitney
right now you'll get your first refill
free that's your first refill free at
get quip dot com slash whitney spell
g-e-t-q-u-i-p
dot com slash whitney quip the good
habits company
gonna go brush my teeth real quick
i've been brushing mine the whole time
you know who else has a great smile
verdas oh and we're going back to that
let's go back to the interview
back back back to the interview
okay this is the the book the tortoise
and the hair and someone just put like a
a jason mask from halloween on him
mask pollution ocean no i think that the
masks the disposable masks are becoming
a pretty nasty uh pollution issue let me
ask you this how many turtles do you
know who have coveted
so the masks are working i'm sorry i
don't know call um god damn it if i was
just funnier i could have said the guy
that played turtle on entourage what's
his name
i like that show
that was one of those jerry
one of the reasons i wanted to come like
over to america and like see that
entourage yeah i was like i want to see
what this shit is all about you know
tell me tell me more i i just remember
watching it and i was
bollywood's comfortable you know god's
been kind and uh there was no intention
to come to america and then
somebody from an agency in america found
me like seven years ago and they're like
come
take some meetings and i was like ooh
like enter like you know that's that's
literally the first thing go on weird
dates yeah
with people so i came over for 10 days
and had general meetings and kind of
went from there but like my reference
was entourage i'm like it's going to be
like andraj and he's like yeah sure
and cut this is a fun story by the way
uh
i'm i saw you perform at the laugh
factory the first time i ever played uh
the u.s
oh no i got like a
a six minute spot at the laugh factory
and uh i followed you
and then dane cook came after like
that's that's what the lineup was i got
like a spot between the two of you yeah
how did i do
you did very well really yeah okay it
was it was good like you did like 10 or
15. we didn't like meat meat i was
probably unconscious at that time
was this like at the height of dane cook
no this was uh
now depending on when i say i'm talking
about when dain coke was at his height
so i don't know but this is like six
years ago seven years ago
oh he got it okay i thought you meant
like 15 years ago i was like oh god
i feel like this is a like weird tampon
kabbalah joke
i remember you coming in and you were
talking to like jamie masada about the
roasts and why you weren't doing roasts
anymore and i just remember being
backstage and i was like yeah that's
actually a good point like why she's not
doing them anymore i just remember that
that's yeah
i made a good point once it's happened
twice it happened once i think that's
that's kind of what that stuff you said
about straws right now that was riveting
that's great get back to the straws
the straws well here's the other thing
is that we're supposed to use the
metal straws or reusable straws and i
was trying to use those and then there
were glass ones and they kept breaking
and i'm like i'm literally eating glass
this cannot be good people already think
that i'm losing my mind so i watch shark
tank a lot and i saw somebody come up
with like a metal collapsible straw
thing and i'm like they're gonna be a
millionaire
nobody bought this shit like all the
sharks were like nah
um do you
love shark tank because on some level
like what look what is the appeal to it
i like
the just the salesmanship that a
non-public speaker is supposed to have
and then amazing either does or doesn't
so you're more interested in the the
pitch person pitching it yeah because
i think we've all been in like rooms
where like a writer has to pitch
something and writers can't pitch
because they're right they're writers
right i know and then all of a sudden
they have to be actors yeah so i love
when people who aren't supposed to pitch
pitch like i love watching that just to
see if they pull it off like i'm at some
level i'm rooting for them saying come
on it makes me uncomfortable it's like
it's why i can't watch ice skating
because i'm just like if they fall i
can't handle i can't it's like it's just
this embarrassment by proxy thing like
you can't watch bad public speaking
because you're a public speaker no the
only thing i can't watch is um kelsey
grammer walking off of the stage
um have you seen this
no what i've not seen this oh my god
he's the guy from frasier right forgive
my asking and i know is he a national
treasure okay because i want to talk
about the hardest you've ever left
um
okay
this is a video
that is very important to me it's healed
many a wound
when i first saw this i laughed so hard
i had to like
take a walk like i had to like pull i
had to like go like get like i know what
it means when someone's like i have to
like pull my shit together like gather
my i had to gather myself okay so this
is kelsey grammer is giving like a talk
at a
college
[Music]
is he rich enough where he's like i'm
gonna buy this college and shut it down
now
because that's what he's thinking like
in his mind he's just like
i will end this institution
for this fall
i own i'm renaming this theater the
kelsey grammer theater kelsey grimmer
did not fall theater
the upright kelsey grammar institute for
the performing arts the never fell off
the stage center performing arts when i
first saw it i just died laughing died
laughing
um
that i can watch
but you can't watch bad public speaking
bad public speaking is just
i'm like let me
like i i feel like i'm a marionette doll
operator who's trying to operate my
puppet and they they're not getting it
are you married i'm married yes and how
long um
five and a half years now and so when
did you know
this is it
what's the difference between i love you
i love you i love you because you said
it before yeah to you're my wife
we
it was really organic like we were
together for like seven years before and
we met
like she gave crashed my housewarming
party this with a friend uh so she was
there and we said hi and then my house
bitch
and then she was an event manager um and
so there was a concert happening and my
band was playing and i think you're
banned yeah i'm i play you know okay you
have four specials you
do arenas and you have a band i have a
really bad comedy rock band called alien
chutney
uh alien chutney yeah that's
so funny um
which is we only do music festivals like
once a year and we have like with
terrorism you do my wedding that won't
ever happen done oh my god that is so
funny and so she uh she ran the concert
because she used to do like jazz
festivals and like run rock concerts and
stuff yeah and then one day we were just
like we're gonna get married and go to
sri lanka and do it like she knows how
to run if she can run a lollapalooza
yeah she can
do mine
run my life yeah so yeah and then
i just kind of knew it was weird like
i don't think i officially proposed
until we were leaving for the wedding
like we were just like we're going to
get married and we're going to do it now
but was it when did you know so i'm
sorry to get granular and i don't mean
to be annoying but like i think
you know people confuse or like i don't
know when were you in love when did it
start when did you know when you not
know like
what's the difference between i love you
but i'm not gonna marry you and i love
you i'm gonna marry you is it instant is
it gradual is it
incremental
it's
for me
um
if it's
if the smallest thing in the world
happens
and i immediately think about telling
you about it i think that's the the
difference because i think in in the
beginning of a relationship it's like
big stuff happen let's talk about that
etc and then it's just like if i if it's
like i had a great sandwich you should
know i had a great sandwich um i don't
want to tell you about that time i want
to tell you about it and what do you
want from that exchange
nothing i don't want you to know i just
want you to know and i just want you to
be know what's inside my body and do you
have a sandwich like as cheesy as that
sounds like did you have a sandwich like
that's what are you eating yeah like
mundane fucking i want to know what else
is in you yeah absolutely tell me
everything that's in you yeah let's talk
about a giant or a salmon yeah sandwich
i want to talk about your
your
what's in your intestines
forget about forget your heart how's
your colony
let's talk i want to know everything you
ate yeah so it's just that i think it's
small shit right over time i don't think
it's
it's it's like
big things i don't think so i like that
because
being with a comedian is a shitty enough
experience for anyone right we work at
night we're always on tour we're always
mining we're always in our head
and i think if you're just able to focus
on something really really small
together then you're both present in
that as opposed to like i have a big
arena coming up or like i have this big
audition coming up etc everybody has
those beats in their life and those will
either happen or not happen
but them being in your life may not
value add to that but this small little
thing that we're doing we can actually
value add to each other's life in that
thing like you can't dictate how my
audition goes or how my arena shows go
but this sandwich or this meal
we can both make that better for each
other like that's the way i look at it
did you have any conflict at all yeah we
i mean we fight as much as husbands and
wives fight i guess and i think for her
you know between
between bollywood and comedy and in
music and all of that there's not a lot
of time you know so we tend to
like our time is just literally nothing
time
you know it's we don't do like date
night or like big vacation or any of
that it's just let's sit in this room
and just hang yes yes yes you know
that's put in the hours yeah put in the
house
and that's the good shit stay connected
yeah i think so that's sick like what is
the one thing like a relationship can't
survive without is it like
taste in movies
taste in music
like there's a couple like what is a
deal breaker like
like how many stars have to align does
that make sense like what if i
i don't know like
i've always been like commitment
happy
you know and and this is so i've never
broken up with a girl like this is my
i've never broken up with anyone in my
life and i've dated a bunch of people so
i'm the guy who like waits for them to
change their mind and
right so like it's shitty and i will
stay in it until they figure it out but
or yeah i'm gonna make i'm gonna be an
asshole till you do it yeah
but i'm happiest in commitment i've
always been happier wow and and that's i
think
also like an indian thing which like
won't fucking die together
this you know the the uber ride the
destination selected we're just in the
back someone else is driving don't you
get out of the fucking car you know
we'll just fuck around and see what
buttons do in the back seat like that's
that's life you know that's fascinating
i mean
somewhere in between like indian
arranged marriages and like modern
nobody's right for me i have to find the
right one go through like multiple
partners somewhere in there is the the
happy space i
i don't know what it is but it's it's
neither one of those things to me
what are the most annoying stereotypes
that are still
sort of in the ether
about like love or about like like
arranged marriages is that even
something that's in the
arranged marriage is awesome just by the
way it is fucking incredible at like
multiple levels because a your parents
know what you need like know you better
then you fucking know yourself let's be
honest your parents know the shittiest
parts of you so if they're finding you a
partner based on the shittiest parts of
you let me save you some time exactly
right
that
also like who gets to say
they fell in love after they got married
like that's a beautiful journey like i
know people who
quoted for like four months or five
months got married and then
five years into marriage were hopelessly
in love could not keep their hands off
each other in love who gets to fucking
say that about marriage that it's an
incredible thing because you both go
into it with these sort of
will build expectations from each other
as we go along we're not going to come
into the relationship with all these
major expected expectations and we have
to be friends first then fall in love
so it i believe in it like it's a good
thing that's sick it's like um uh
kourtney kardashian sorry i never talk
about the kardashians but we did wendy
williams last week and travis barker
like they were friends first you know
what i mean yeah and then it was like oh
you
like people were like you guys should
date you know what i mean it's like it's
kind of
i don't think we are able to
be the best decision makers of who we
should date
like other people should pick
i hire a stylist you know it's like i
don't i don't always know what looks
good on me i i don't always i'm not
gonna set design this podcast studio
like i'm gonna hire someone you tell me
who you think i should date also
you won't know if you're leveling up or
settling when you're picking a person
right but your parents kind of do yeah
i've seen so many indian men level the
fuck up in an arranged marriage
situation
where i'm like this person is way out of
your league
and your parents just came through for
you in a gigantic way like like you she
is a nine you are a six
like thank your mom and shut the fuck up
and live your life
you know
is it um
uh that's so funny uh nikki cannodia you
met my best friend from college nikki
canodia she her dad she's an indian but
her dad came here and gave wanted to
give them like intentionally very
american names
nikki megan
uh neil and um
her she had an indian wedding and then a
wedding like two weddings the indian
wedding was
the most fun yes i have ever had did you
do the did you dress up and i dressed up
i feel like if i showed you a photo i
would get canticles cancelled no one's
why it's an appropriation why can't
people do that anymore like why can't
you dress up in like an indian outfit i
mean i didn't put on like i didn't put
like you know
you didn't do that shit all right that's
fine girl like full julian huff like i
didn't
totally
you know but it's not like you're making
a profit off of your outfit at the
indian wedding you're just trying to
feel involved like what's wrong with
that
yeah you're trying to fit in
i i like putting by the way i like
putting just non-indians in indian
clothing because then i get to see them
look nervous
i don't get to see them look nervous
well it blows your mind because like she
came out in red you know she was like
and that she was like okay we're like
planning the wedding and everything and
i'm like what i'm gonna wear she's like
you're white i'm like what to you i'm
wearing white to your wedding that
mind-blown so white to us is what we
wear when people die just by the way
like if you're ever going to an indian
funeral like don't wear black just wear
white
that's
fyi in case anybody needs to know that
okay
let's do like a couple quick you know
what we do red flags a lot on the show
let's do red flags
in india red flags for guys go top five
okay um
if you so don't assume that the girl or
that everybody's conservative because
that's like some 1975 version of india
that you've been led to believe by pop
culture people in india smoke drink do
drugs fuck hook up and have a good time
that's number one so i want to represent
my people correct okay right uh two
always talk to the girl's parents first
now
uh
i think uh
don't don't talk about like uh
like do you guys know this person like
this like that that's a very like
not american thing but also a british
thing as well where you come over and
like do you know that guy and we're like
no we don't know that guy we're like a
billion people busy with each other so
we won't know a lot of the references
like a famous person or
a famous person or also like sometimes
i'll meet americans who are like do you
know pooja
like from delhi and i'm like there's 26
million people in delhi how the fuck do
i know yes exactly okay the arrogance of
americans that are like
okay do you yeah do you know um the
jonas brother's wife priyanka yeah i
actually do know
but
you know
don't do that um
don't don't pay for shit until you ask
us how much it costs because just you
know
like you're being charged 400 for
everything so just like check with an
indian like am i being fucked here or
like does this actually cost what it
costs like if you're just doing like
shopping
um you're not gonna find yourself just
because you came to india you should
know that shit as well like it's like
not everything is spiritual you know so
you're not gonna leave forever changed
because you came to india once you're
gonna leave forever changed because you
grew as a person no matter what where
the fuck you were
india or no india and finally wherever
you go there you are yeah
and finally not ruin it i always feel i
always felt bad for india because it was
like all the craziest people are going
from america are going to india to try
to go to like find god like all these
like crazy people i mean oh show bikram
we're not really sending you pearls
either you know what i'm saying it's not
like
dude
how dare you
uh who is
wild wild country yeah who's the woman
ma anand sheila
sheila is an amazing woman he is an
amazing he's an amazing woman yeah
a pearl a diamond how dare you sheila if
you're out there my offer still stands
to run my company
tough titties right that was tough
titties i love that she's amazing i love
her yeah
so no that's it that's those are my five
things kris jenner she
all sex cults
is that what we're equating like the
kardashian mother to
is genius i love her she's the oprah of
the
just wrong just went in the wrong
direction
she knew the
assignment beep beep
what are you backing up out of this
interview into another ad
oh ads again it's time for ads again uh
still haven't found whitney yeah we and
we quit looking honestly so because we
like all this camera time
smile smile um i if you're listening
we're smiling um
this is article okay we're talking about
article why because we've been traveling
a lot me and whitney and emily we've
been traveling all over the united
states and more places honestly can use
article we have come in contact with
lots of furniture and it's not
um a scandinavian
breeze of joy modern exciting like
they're like here's a video we were in
um this beautiful casino doing a show
and uh there was it was christmas time
so whitney went into you know like oh
just it's ecstatic she loves christmas
yeah but
you know what ruined christmas what that
it wasn't article furniture let's take a
look at that
oh did you get this from article
you know this is not from article
unfortunately
this is the perfect setup for me which
is two christmas trees in the middle of
november is my dream but the only
problem is this is not an article bench
and if you feel like it would be better
if it was right if it was an article
bench i would i would never leave you'd
never leave this spot because i was
looking at this
it's just not this bench is nice but
article is it's it's so this one's a
little cheap yeah it's not modern it's
not delivered right to your door it's
not scandinavian
you know what i mean it's not like clean
and modern and like cool yeah it's not
easy to assemble it's not timeless
that's right this has an expiration date
it expired in 1993 with dracar noir this
had an expiration date it's january 1st
wow as you can see
not thrilled that it was an article no
no it would have made the experience
better our bodies have become accustomed
to article
design and comfort so i can understand
buttery beautiful furniture article is
the easiest way to make your space look
beautiful article combines the curation
of a boutique furniture store with the
comfort and simplicity of shopping
online fast affordable shipping is
available across the usa and canada and
is free on orders over 999 dollars
articles offering our listeners 50 off
your first purchase of 100 or more go to
article.com whitney and the discount
will be automatically applied at
checkout that's article.com whitney to
get 50 off your first portraits
[Music]
100 or more they make that as easy as
assembling article furniture they do it
comes right i mean it's truly the best
it really is i mean every time i walk
into my apartment i'm like i get to live
in this apartment i know i feel like i
live in an article website i love it and
i i do yeah they bought the whole floor
plan yeah oh article you should really
go get that for christmas it'll it it's
just go buy it trust us yeah
um another thing i like to do on my
article furniture is
play best fiends i love best fiends i
know i play it all the time i caught old
girl playing it the other day she was
trying uh she's not as good as me at
best fiends right but she did she'd give
it a try and i did catch her in the act
well thank god let's watch it this is
her playing best fiends in the airport
what are you doing we're supposed to be
getting our luggage it's not here yet
well how would you know if it even came
around if you're doing oh you're playing
best fiends okay
sometimes i think you're my best
friend at other times
i'm a slug i think you're a slug i wish
you were a slug listen no
look at these halloween costumes they're
still no look how cute hold on
oh one of them's on a date night
hopefully i feel like when i play this
it like gets my brain ready to do stand
up it like wakes it up i like have
coffee yeah because it activates it for
sure
how come i'm not getting any
stop looking at my strategies yeah we'd
hate to figure out that i love this guy
so much like oh i know this guy's so
cute he just leveled up
so cute look at this guy ah that's emily
i like i love the ones on a date night
okay
do you feel like um
do you feel like you want to play
against me should i open mine no
no because you don't want to lose you're
not my best fiend anymore
wow
good thing there's millions of downloads
i can play with other people
didn't go do that
okay good luck getting millions of other
people you'll bother did you know
oh
you guys have been spending a lot of
time she gets real aggressive when she
plays best fiends yes mostly because
she's not as good at it as me yeah but i
mean it is a really fun game it's a
puzzle game it activates your brain
there are millions of downloads tons of
people playing it you can play with them
unique gameplay that means has it all
and it's always changing so you're never
doing the same thing you can level up
all your characters yeah even the little
emily love love love love was that emily
one hot that emily character well it was
a it was a
butterfly in a cocoon but i guess that
could be hot depending on if you're a
freak best fiends has it all an amazing
storyline collectible fiends and tons of
fun puzzles just like live
i can't put it down it's quite possibly
the best game out there you can play it
anywhere no wi-fi is required which is
incredible on a plane no problem best
fiends wherever whenever you want with
the offline mode oh that's awesome so
even if you're in holiday travels take
you to off the beaten path you can still
play best fiends you can play best
fiends off the beaten path with bugs
while you play as your bug with the bugs
you know what i mean download best
fiends for you today on the app store or
google play that's friends without the r
best fiends
okay
we have another ad one more ad and i
know that you guys miss whitney and you
wish she was here but she's way too
horny to be here and you'll see why
ladies look i'm not saying i know
everything but there is one thing that i
know for sure no matter what he says
brett from tinder is not the cure for a
low sex drive
he may be hot he may drive a nice car
heck
he may even have an okay personality but
for some of us our frustrating low
libido is more complicated than that in
fact it could be a medical condition
called hypoactive sexual desire disorder
or hsdd hsdd is the most common form of
sexual dysfunction in pre-menopausal
women
just because we don't talk about it
doesn't mean we're not feeling it right
whether you're single sifting through
endless breaths on dating apps or
married with kids losing your desire for
sex
is hard to accept
and you don't have to
meet addie or flip answering the fda
approved little pink pill for certain
pre-menopausal women frustrated by their
low sex drive are you ready to learn
more about this if so
head over to addie
a-d-d-y-i
dot-com and schedule an online visit
today use code good for you at checkout
and find out if addie could be good for
you
for only ten dollars that's good for you
at a d d y i dot com
addie
a d d y i
is for premenopausal women with acquired
generalized hypoactive or low
sexual desire disorder hsdd
who have not had problems with low
sexual desire in the past and who have
low sexual desire no matter the type of
sexual activity the situation or the
sexual partner the low sexual desire is
troubling to them it is not due to
medical or
a mental health problem
problem in the relationship or medicine
or other drug use
addie is not for use in men
or to enhance sexual performance your
risk of severe low blood pressure and
fainting is increased if you drink one
to two standard alcoholic drinks close
in time to your addy dose wait at least
two hours after drinking before taking
addie at bedtime your risk of severe low
blood pressure and fainting is also
increased if you take certain
prescription over-the-counter or herbal
medications or have liver problems
low blood pressure and fainting can
happen when you take addie even if you
don't drink alcohol or take other
medicines do not take if you're allergic
to any of the ingredients in addie
allergic reactions may include hives
itching or trouble breathing sleepiness
sometimes serious can occur common side
effects include dizziness nausea
tiredness difficulty falling asleep or
staying asleep and dry mouth see full pi
and medication guide including boxed
warning at addie.com
pi or call 844
pink pill learn about the little pink
pill addie at a d d y i
dot com
thanks whitney for that riveting story
about women's sexuality
back to verdas back to you verdas on the
streets
i've watched the kardashians actually
like i actually like that show i have
not seen a lot of it
what do you think i like it like it's a
strange take on like american celebrity
which i like like it's the closest
american celebrity comes to bollywood
celebrity like bollywood celebrity is
insane right so like the top 10
bollywood stars
it's like
you know if brad pitt walked down like
melrose or whatever he'd be able to walk
down the street right without
too much
bother i think in la yeah in los angeles
in mumbai if shahrukh khan who's the
biggest bollywood star stepped out for
like 30 seconds there'd be a stampede
and there'd be 5 thousand people on the
street and that's like bollywood fame
and i think like the kardashians have
that fame
you know i think kim kardashian's more
famous than brad pitt i could be wrong
am i wrong there's a there's a certain
um you're making me think of something
more
like philosophical which is what your
work as the comedian does like you you
you're a like a philosopher or
in your comedy and in your comedy
it makes me think differently like the
way you put the you plant these little
seeds in people's brains that you can't
un that have to freaking bloom or
whatever well that sounds hilarious
it's like a chia pet
um
but
you know like the concept of fame i
think that
americans like there's this thing where
there's different people are famous
to different people like there's
different kinds of fame now number one
number two i think that
there's this thing in america where
if you see a famous person yeah
you don't think you're
beneath them
sure necessarily yeah and there's a
little bit of like oh i'm not gonna say
anything because like i don't embarrass
myself
like cause i might work with this person
one day because i like everyone in
america i think
that i well maybe it's just people i
surround myself with but like i think
there's a little bit of a
i'm a celebrity too
so i'm my own celebrity but
why not is my question like why not have
that
sort of
self audacity if you will you know self
love self love yeah why not you know
like where i come from there's a lot of
hero worship and then there's a lot of
that's a celebrity let's go fuck with
that guy right now you know there's a
lot of the comment section yeah that
which is the same thing as the comment
section like yeah so it's like when like
the i just i love what you're saying
because when i visualize
you know
100 people running up to a famous
bollywood star i'm like oh my god that's
the comment section some people like
fuck you i don't like your movies i love
your movies dude your last movie was
better than the other one like that
that's just the comment section
you know for bollywood stars yeah i feel
like comedians we have our own kind of
comment section relationship and then
some of them are just trying to fuck
with you some of them are just trying to
be funny some people are trying to roast
you and they're
trying to be funny but they're not and
it's just like a joke gone sideways well
i mean that i'm assuming that's
something that you have to deal with
much more than i do which is sort of
insecure men trying to be funnier than
comedians you know
like isn't that a large part of your
comment section sorry i'm googling
bollywood stars
right now this guy is this the guy you
were talking about yeah shahrukh khan
that's the biggest star in the world
pretty much
like in terms of everything in terms of
fan base in terms of reach in terms of
anything that's fascinating like every
sunday he will have 10 000 people
waiting outside his house there's
something fascinating about this because
there's something very um
alpha is a word that is just i just
think has lost its meaning um much like
genius and hilarious and all those
brilliant all those other words
but there's something
you know why guys like him and girls
like him it's very rare for for men and
women to like the same man and he's also
just like
like a romantic leading man so like
who's the valentino was that the guy who
was just like the legendary romantic
like in black and white movies the um
casablanca i think so like nobody
romances a woman like shahrukh khan
romance as a woman is is something that
you find people saying like he just
knows how to do love on camera romance
is a woman
like
on screen harvey weinstein
wait who is our who is our
him who's the american version of him of
shah rukh khan
good lord um
who's your big like a big someone that i
don't even you guys don't know
sure
yeah he's the the off-screen version of
shit he's pete davison yeah
that guy has something going on i don't
know what it is but there's something
there but that's fascinating but as a
performer some of the you know you
hypnotize you know 100
maybe you know i don't know
thousands of people um
what is it is it charisma is it
um
yeah i think charisma i think also he's
his story is really good like he has a
self-made you know showed up in mumbai
with nothing but a suitcase and kind of
became king of the world story and i
think people
you know relate to that aspire to that
and just yeah he's like i still
like our version of the oscars i used to
write jokes for that and he used to host
it and like you'd be up in his house
just like pitching jokes to the guy and
then
he'd never listen to you he'd go on and
do his version of the joke and it would
always be better and like nobody's ever
done that like i've always written jokes
for people and then they go and do their
own version and it sucks and i think you
know that feeling as well when they when
they don't do the jokers you write it
but this guy would just go on and do the
joke and it would fucking be better so
you're just backstage in the wings like
fuck that was good whoa
you know he's that good he's just that
smart and what
that's mind-blowing yeah do you um
this is the part of the podcast where i
ask about your ancestral trauma all
right cool done is there any like in in
like ancestral like what is that what do
you carry like do you feel like you
carry a belief system that is like
rooted in any kind of like guilt shame
need to entertain need to be masculine
feminine like do you feel like there are
any
sort of like old paradigms that you're
working to kind of try to break within
yourself
yeah i think for me
feeling like i'm always two steps
removed from poverty is is one wow so
like never chilling
long enough and never sitting long
enough because i'm like this could be
gone any second now let's keep going you
know so never really
sitting back and enjoying anything
because i'm like onto the next on to the
next have to keep this going
um not just for myself but for the
people that i work with and that's one
and then also i think um
i'm a bit of a mutt you know where i uh
like i didn't grow up in india and i
grew up in africa and then i went to
college in america but i'm so like i'm
very western for india and i'm very
india for the west so just kind of that
nowhere guy is the thing that i i can't
do yes and then the question of like
what is the common denominator in all of
us that of being exposed to so many
different um continents um i wanted to
you remind me of marina abramovic
marina abramovic is one of my favorite
people on the planet
she's a performance artist uh who did
this installation remember where she sat
oh yeah basically across from somebody
for 15 minutes at the met in new york
and made eye contact with them for 15
minutes and strangers would just come
look at her for 15 minutes and they
would always they would
inevitably cry everyone would go in and
go everyone would just cry and it's
called the artist's present was the
installation
she's an incredible performance artist
and didn't shy with the booth do a
version of this which just he cried like
i think that was just surveillance
footage of his like a late night on
tuesday
um but uh yeah she's incredible her book
is incredible um and
i think sexton city did a like a funny
thing about her um but
i love her and i used to have her
manifesto printed out
um
because that's how
obsessed with her i got so marina
manifest artist manifesto so she has
basically a list of the things
that you should have and when you're
talking about like your belongings and
selling your house and all this stuff
there's rules um an artist should stay
for long periods of time looking at the
stars in the night sky so this is like
the rules that an artist should live by
okay
it's like
i don't know if it's
whatever i mean i don't abide by them
obviously
um
i'm not an artist i'm just a mess
but i mean isn't i mean this is
philosophical but that's what an artist
is right a mess yeah hopefully i hope
i'm a mess you know um but it's like uh
old-fashioned rules of personal conduct
the kind of which artists like uh
blah blah blah i can't pronounce any of
those words
okay an artist should not lie to himself
or others this is like the artist
manifesto an artist should not lie to
himself or others an artist should not
steal ideas from other artists an artist
should not compromise for himself
or in regards to the art market an
artist should not kill
other human beings okay
an artist
i'm just thinking about how many of
these like just in general show business
has failed uh you know like it's like
like we're all for all my brain just
went you shouldn't steal from other
artists yeah and you should not kill
well you just stole from the
commandments
because that's isn't that that shall not
kill okay whatever
an artist should avoid falling in love
with another artist
yeah
yes
an artist
an artist relation to silence an artist
has to understand silence
an artist has to create space for
silence to enter his work
silence is like an island in the middle
of a turbulent ocean
an artist's relation to solitude
an artist must make time for long
periods of solitude solitude is
extremely important away from home away
from the studio away from family away
from friends
an artist should stay for long periods
of time at waterfalls
an artist should stay like tlc can i
watch the tlc music video i feel like
she's losing it by the end or like like
she's just getting more and more
privileged that she's she's like an
artist should drink prosecco
an artist should stay at the ritz and
artists should like she's just getting
richer and richer she writes this shit
stay for long time at the waterfalls at
the st regis maldives
uh the waterfalls it's the name of the
restaurant uh over at the ritz carlton
an artist should stay for long periods
of time looking at the horizon where the
ocean and sky meet that is there's
actually a neurological uh benefit to
that as well but i don't think that's
what she's talking about an artist
should stay for long periods of time
looking at the stars in the sky
have a good bullshit detector fear
nothing and no one be tender you are
such a
such an expert on human nature like do
you think
we need hate
like is it part of is it you know
because like stop
hate like
stop disagreeing like is that something
can ever really go away
no i i just think that i mean
in my country
it's fed to people because of religion
like really archaic systems right so
and now it's
you know
the conversation of privilege in the
west
leading to hatred right uh because of
oppression systemic racism etc etc
leading to hatred is a slightly
a slightly earlier version of that is
happening in my country which is because
of religion and you know i don't think
too many people hate people because of
their religion in america
but they hate people because of the
color of their skin or their nationality
etcetera etcetera so it's a man oh yeah
sure
i used to have one for like a short
period of time for a really short period
are you starting a cult no i was just in
a pandemic and and there was no haircuts
or anything so i had one and it was
really sad
and
it took my hairline like up half a
centimeter but yeah there's that's
that's what nobody talks about right
it's the guy with the man who's balding
like five years later because he was a
hipster for five years you know who now
has no hair
you could not rely on a hipster i feel
attacked i had a man
i am very pro man bun now
no are you
like by the way
39 and childless don't listen to me
i feel like women no longer want to see
men's faces now like beards are a thing
like you're like i'm okay with half your
face i don't want to see the lower half
of your face
with the masks not just the masks like i
feel like
women don't like clean shaved men
anymore interesting like i think that
went away five years ago oh
you i think in a lot of places in
america that was
never
went away like it was always beards you
know like i family and you know virginia
and south like beards never were out of
style yeah this whole thing that when
they're like williamsburg we're gonna
grow beards like yeah you mean like
every man that
makes the
farms the corn you're eating at your
fucking chipotle
and um
but
clean shaven here's the problem
you either ought to be super super clean
or susan
grown out in between
that is a rug burn on the face for me ah
so
it's i don't look at it as like
aesthetic or not it's just if you have a
five o'clock shout out that's physical
violence if we make out
you're hurting me we don't time's up
um i will that is the real
harassment you are physically injuring
me during this consensual makeout
session because you didn't bother to
freaking shave this morning i get the
grown out thing because that's uh like
an evolution thing because i think men
with beards like
biologically are supposed to be like you
know supposed to activate female
responses so i get that
not an option for me a brown man
international traveler a really long
beard not a good idea just for airports
and things like that you know
will activate female and other responses
uh
if if i travel but tsa pre-check do i
say i
by the way i look at that shit like it's
the holy grail like just to be able to
walk through that thing like i
so i'm flying good airlines and but i
look at tsa pre-check just like someday
man i'm to go through it can you get it
in america i cannot no like
i
you you fly
26 hours to get to america and then you
land in lax which is an airport from
1986. i'm sorry all right
at best and then you wait for three more
hours lax
i feel like lax is russia
i feel like russia would feel
differently
when i land there i'm like this feels
like what russia is
like just 80s like unfair yeah not cool
it's too cold there's no wi-fi
like i'm confused
the escalators don't make any sense like
i was like i always feel like i'm in
like st petersburg but i've never been
there it's two hours to three hours of
standing in a line after 28 hour journey
and then you're supposed to be like you
pre-check and then then you're just like
i'm happy to be in america because
you're just like no i if you're not a
citizen can you not get yeah i don't
think you can i don't think you can i
mean i did have to drive to van nuys
it's a it's a day of your life to get
pre-checked really
that's it
i mean it's a day you have to like
submit an application i had to drive in
i did like do an interview
sometimes i guess you could do it in the
airport they now have little kiosks in
the airport where you can do it but i
don't know what's clear what about clear
i don't even think i can do that or
global pass no i think i have to like
make eye contact and talk to everybody
in the airport i think that's what i
have to do that's my journey can i be a
dickhead please do it's also why you're
gonna stay so relevant so funny because
comedians when they get too rich and
famous and successful
they start they stop in you know in
order for art to imitate life you have
to have a life it's like
they stop having everyday exchanges with
people and seeing how disgusting human
beings actually are and like engaging in
what's actually going on so it's
probably keeping you funny and
observational
and
in the zeitgeist and delayed everywhere
it's keeping you having amazing jokes
that you won't be able to tell because
you're you will miss your flight it's
true yeah it
ah i like i said i love so many things
about this country if there's only two
things i would change i would just
upgrade every plane in every airport
like i would buy
every airline a new set of planes and i
would change all of your airports that's
the first thing i would do they're bad
huh they're just they're not bad they're
just old like they're really like if you
go to singapore or mumbai or bangkok or
anywhere in the world
yeah except for like heathrow
and charles de gaulle and america and
these are just ancient airports from the
first world just by the way
i can't believe we're talking about this
but there's nothing more i want to talk
about so airports
dude
airports in america are a nightmare i've
never thought about that you have third
world airports that welcome people to
the first world allegedly like that's
basically what you have i'm sorry if
that's offensive but it's true
dude that is so fucking true it's like
people go welcome to america the land of
hudson news yeah like what is this trash
bag of a place like a nightmare it is
squid games everyone's in those like
neon masks like carrying your luggage it
is a nightmare and i think dulles have
you ever flown into washington dulles
yeah that they renovated and now it kind
of is almost like too futuristic or
something but
every airport i was talking about this
with benton the other day i was like
i don't remember the last time i was at
an airport that wasn't under
construction
like i just assume all airports
are just under construction like there's
no such thing as an airport that's done
so
it's stupid and cheesy but i love an
airport like it's one of my favorite
places in the world it means you have to
go make money
yeah yeah yeah yeah i have to have lost
dogs yeah i know what this means i was
gonna be all like pretentious to be like
i can watch people but i think i like
the money thing better like
i know what happens when i do this
action
yeah because your only way to make money
that makes sense or you've just made
money and you're on the way back to
spend that money that's gonna clear it
yeah
i mean
yeah i hadn't thought of that that way
what is this is a stupid question but i
love it
what is your favorite airport in america
my favorite airport in america would
have to be in city
favorite city would have to be
dc
what yeah because nobody's from dc
everybody's from elsewhere and so it's
like this nice metropolitan lively
international crowd they just get the
world so i like dc you know all this
it's just because like i'd work the dc
improv and then i gig in dc now quite a
bit so i like dc for that reason where
everybody's just they know a little bit
more about the world than
not dc you know
and my favorite airport would have to be
san jose airport
just because i came from the last
weekend and it's five feet long it is
it's very it's like a kiosk yeah so you
just get on the plane san jose is really
nice san jose california because it's a
lot of people um
around the silicon valley too so it's
like tech people yeah they got their
shit together it's like you know
the
next steve jobs is flying in the airport
you know what i mean like so they have
they have their shit together and i like
chicago like i love chicago
uh not the airport but i just i used to
i love chicago i used to be a dishwasher
in chicago at the grand lux cafe on
michigan avenue like that was my job
after college so i love that city like i
just have good memories i love chicago
best crowds best best best crafts really
yeah i still like dc for crowds i don't
know why don't you no i shot two of my
specials in dc yeah sydney harmon hall
my first one and the one that i just did
because dc crowds are
it's such an amalgam a great cross
section of all kinds of people and yeah
i shoot specials pretty much
there
you are like are you feeling like you
have a new one like with your new toe
and all of that stuff like i'm still
feeling it out like i don't feel like i
have like a
legs yet i feel like i'm just happy to
be back on the road and happy to be
gigging again
i
feel like
um
i don't want to
like self-indulge um i'd rather you talk
but
i
it's weird because i i'm trying this new
hour i was like i'm going to go so
personal i'm going to just be more and
more personal more and more personal and
you know if anyone has a similar joke
than you
it just means you're not being personal
enough just go more personal go deeper
go more specific and
and then um i was talking about a
relationship i was in which is
i'm not really in anymore and i'm like
ugh did i just lose a half hour um
so it's i'm not sure i either have a
great hour
or nothing
i'd have to i have to check myself you
either have like a
a special or a youtube video you have
nothing in between like you have a tick
tock or like an hour long special that's
gonna be your next release
i either have a new hour or i'm retired
um
so
yes i i'm definitely right i think
i'm ready i i liked what you said on um
when targeting podcasts where you would
like book an arena
and then start writing the material
because there were no clubs in india
so i like when i started doing stand-up
in india there were no comedy clubs so
there was nowhere to run like 10 minutes
so i'd have to book a theater and like
write 90 minutes and then go up with 19
new minutes
so you're just screaming at the audience
from this blah blah blah no dynamics
nothing just to see what fucking works
and then you do that for like two months
and then you'd start to feel
it's basically running 90 minutes as a
spot like that's how we started doing
stand up
nuts can i ask you i always ask this
when i'm doing um
like press for each state in america i'm
not worried about getting cancelled
because there's no such thing as like
universal cancellation everyone finds
different things offensive
um what would get you cancelled in india
like what's the worst thing if i went on
stage i tried to do a tour in india a
couple years ago um
it didn't work out for litany of reasons
but like what would be the things that i
could absolutely not say okay uh i'll
answer that but just preface to that is
i don't say this to like drama bravado
or to sound like a victim or anything
like that right um
you've been doing you've been in my
podcast for three hours you are
officially a victim all right done um
i had 14 legal notices last year like 14
legal no cases for jokes like i went to
the second highest court in the land
twice to defend jokes i spent more on
lawyers than i did earn on a lot of the
projects that i did
that's my version of cancelled you know
where the government funds legal cases
against you and you have to fight for so
i went to the high court and won
um
[Music]
you know a case for my jokes so
sometimes when i'm like people are
trolling this guy on twitter or people
are mad at him or they're being dragged
i'm just like that's a dream like that's
really that would be the dream
in terms of like that's my version of
cancer culture what are you saying
it's that's yeah that was my last year
i went to court 14 like i had 14 cases i
went to court twice to defend my jokes
that's cancer culture
i'm sorry i just have to so can i ask
what the jokes the joke
ironically for fucking lawyer jokes
no for lawyers no yeah i i did a show
where i played a shitty comedian who was
also a serial killer hold on so really
quick was it something recorded or
something alive it was a netflix series
oh so you had to defend something that
was filmed but why wouldn't the
production company have to isn't no we
all went to court together like three of
us went to court together but i called
lawyers rapists with pens
in some sort of a
and i got taken to court so and then i
do a lot of religious materials i don't
know what grounds blasphemy yeah
defamation defamation etc etc
but it's not really lawyers taking you
to court it's the establishment it's the
gov we have a very far right wing
conservative trying to control the
narrative
government
so yeah that's my version of cancer
culture it's which is you know you have
to drive downtown yeah yeah
it was on zoom i took oh yeah court yeah
that's the whole thing yeah
so that's so
here's my two cents on it um
whatever the cancer culture thing is
even i don't fully understand it i do
know that comedy is changing and that
it's now going to be
a conversation
like it used to be you'd do jokes people
would laugh and you'd go home
and i think what we need to get used to
is comics is we will do jokes and people
will laugh and go home and there might
be a conversation after that
and much like i would never tell you
what to like i'd never tell you what to
laugh at and i never let you tell me
what i could or couldn't say and i think
that's a fair trade yes but if i've
taken your money i have to honor your
opinion good or bad like i i at least
have to be willing to acknowledge the
conversation
yeah i mean
it's look i i'm so
i you know i i don't want to sound like
a broken record on this but it's like
yeah it's like comedians in the states
now they're like first remember right i
should be able to say whatever i want
and then someone's like i don't think
you're funny they're like
fuck you he's like no so they're not
allowed to say what they want but you
are like what is it so if someone
doesn't think you're funny now they
don't get to have a first amendment
right all of a sudden because you're a
baby a big baby you know if you're not
taking me to court you can say what the
fuck you like as far as i'm concerned if
you're not suing me or my family if
you're not threatening me say what the
fuck you like i have a thick skin i'm a
comic i'll make it is it kind of fun to
tour in the states because yeah it is
fun to say shit and not worry you know
it is and then i know you were just in
san diego but what is what's up with
your tour in the states um
i have
six theaters left so i'm doing like town
hall in new york i'm doing huge huge
boston okay so
with the wilbur theater that is sold out
why don't you add some shows um and then
dc is not sold out that's the kennedy
center so that's the dude the kennedy
center
have you been there i i did a smaller
room and this is my first time in the
big room that's
can you shoot it just for yourself i'm
going to shoot okay good good yeah so i
mean performing the kennedy center that
is yeah that that's where the mark twain
price happens you know like that's
yeah
i have cried outside the kennedy center
in a parked car so many times um
boston massachusetts that is when uh on
the 20th really just austin and boston
have tickets left which is austin on the
and also here's what i'll say is that
these vaccine requirements the mass
everything's changing sometimes people
even if something says sold out show up
anyway because sometimes people
aren't cool with the vaccine
requirements or whatever
you know we don't make the rules the
venue makes the rules um and sometimes
people are like i'm pregnant i don't
want to
do that and there's a ticket available
so just even if it says sold out show up
anyway
um because there might be a ticket
available austin texas paramount theater
that is awesome atlantic city music box
on
uh at the borgata resort on the 13th of
november oh wow that's soon
um
boston on the 20th oh my god i actually
am a friend of mine i'm going to send uh
to come see you
um okay i have a list of things that i
wanted to follow up on
just so you know
i have got to let you go because this is
i'm i'm
obsessed with you
you were very kind for having me on in
the first place like i had a wonderful
time i
am all over the place and
this was a great conversation you were
not all over the place
and i'm so overwhelmed with how many
things i want to talk to you about that
i feel like we didn't get to anything my
list of questions i wrote for you okay
well i hope you will come back i would
love i hope i can con you or guilt you
into coming back
at some point because i wrote all these
dorky ass questions for you it's fine we
had a good conversation it's just very
rare that you know like i get to
i'm like i fan i'm fanning out on you
like i just i was listening to yourself
this weekend it made me
re uh spotify you know you have all
these specials on netflix like it just
it made me want to work harder and it
made me proud to be a comedian it made
me want to
try harder it made me
want to think more deeply it made me um
proud it was like oh yeah being a
comedian is
is noble
what i will say and i want to say this
before i leave is you know
you should know that there are people
watching you from across the world
and that
what you're doing
is something to be watched and you give
people aspirations with the things that
you're doing so you should always know
that i know sometimes you know like the
the comedy bubble in wherever you are
tends to feel like that bubble but you
should just know that there's comedians
across the world and people across the
world watching your stuff i follow you
on instagram etc
you're doing things that give people
aspiration so you should know that oh my
gosh they're like well if if she can
make it i i'll be fine
you know what i mean if this is
something that makes money i should do
that for a living
um i end these awkwardly it's always
weird that's fine but what else is there
anything else we need to drive people to
you by the way unfollow him on twitter
please do unfollow his social media he's
too popular it's annoying
seeing that 7.7 million you're like
hurtful
no i have nothing else to promote i just
want to come hang it's so funny it's
like i feel like your um
tagline for just you as a person should
be like and you thought you were famous
like it's like you think you're doing
well and then you're like oh fuck like i
thought i was doing well but could you
like mess you fuck up the bell curve
well there's a billion of us like i'm
not gonna you know like there's there's
a billion of us that that's the answer
are you saying that that like
2 million here is the same as 7 million
there there's a lot of us and and
bollywood movies
go everywhere yeah you know that's yeah
that's that's what it is you're dreaming
i look forward to uh
an audience that don't have and i really
i'm dead serious i really hope you and
your wife will stay
here next time you come yes i love you
thank you thank you don't ride elephants
[Music]
four four four
[Applause]